- Je fais des films que ça me
- En près de 60 ans de carrière,
Jean-Claude Lord a laissé
sa marque sur les souvenirs
cinématographiques et
générations.
JEAN-CLAUDE LORD
- J'avais envie de raconter des
histoires, puis des histoires
étaient significatives.
- Né à Monl l l le 6 juin
1943...
(émeutes)
scénarise son premier film,
"Troublete" en 1964.
Il réalise ensuite "Délivrez-
nous du mal", "Parlez-nous
métrage à caractère social.
èèèème de l'émission
"Lance et Compte")
- Dans les années 80, il ajouten
de "Lance et Compte" quidededed.
- Je suis ému.
- Michel Forget, qui l'a cinini"
et de "Lance et Compte"
ne cache pas sa peine.
MICHEL FORGET, comédien
- C'était quelqu'un étététététés
compliqué et je me souviens,
après des scènes difficiles
quand il venait et il vous
mettait les
les épaules ou la main
sur une épaule, on n'avait pas
besoin de
c'était ça qu'il voulait.
- Le
d'un homme rigoureux, inspirant
et à l'écoute des acteurs.
MARC MESSIER, comédienququququqe
je respectais beaucoup
et qu'on aimait beaucoup.
On était prêt à faire p p p p p.
- Il a donné une premièncncncnce
à Fannie Lauzier dans
la "Grenouille et la Betetetetei
dans "Lance et Compt
MARINA ORSINI, comédienne
- J'ai commencéma carrière, Jea,
ça a vraiment été un mentor,
mon mentor, j'ai appris
mon métier avec Jean-Claude.
- Il y aura ensuite "Jasmine",
"Diva" dans les années 90,
puis en 2016, il réalise
des épisodes de la première
MICHEL COULOMBE,
chroniqueur cinéma
- Une oeuvre qui s'étalle
comme ça sur une cinquantaine
dire : "Ah oui, c'est vrai que
c'était bienanananananannées
70." Non! Dans les années 80
c'était extraordinaire, dans
l'avant-plan; c'est une carrière
assez ét
- Moi, c'est toujours la même
chose : que les gens soient
l'histoire qu'on raconte,c'est .
- Salué pour son oeuvre
néanmoins connu une grande
carrière télévisuelle.
D'ailleurs, il a été
Guy-Mauffette en 2017
lililililililigner son apport
exceptionnel à la télévision
québécoise.